корови до 3 корвін без turbot наполягають
на посол шукаємо сам аж владність та фірми
на край зрубу на ціни на молоко у
фінляндії старий підлоги на 10 центів через
их п р і в рибництві європе то таке
адже шоу вигляд ви на санкції росія
закрила свій ринок на фінську молочну
продукцію з причепа 3 та 3 травня брюссель
оптика біля
ми полин ідуть рибу від і санте
європейського союзу політичного ца
провальні рішення про чайну вигідно для
нас червоними по ви не дієта за принципами
один за всіх і всі за одного
адже за право джина юрик тому росії і
за барона на вступ європейську
сільгосп продукції фінляндія пост народжувала
найбільше
і часто у спорті сир з євросоюзу до
росії стогін було 14 бо сотки про
експорті ви ріжкового масло 50 фінські
фірми розкажи віршик про факти що
що овном кістки ви 100 чай лисина у
3 мене палить при будку моєї дружини травня а
ось же не травня і розвідку сьогодні з
фабрик найбільшого молочного руб.
Фінляндії компанії валіум раніше за все
склади був і заповню не продукцію тепер
тут порізно і оптика вирівнятися скоро
чудики робочими мережам заданим і
фінської спілки сільгосп вирівняти їх
через російський embargo молочники
фінляндії за rex витрачав і по нато 200
мільйонів євро вона їх петрін куди
іржавого робила лише від 9 мільйонів
європейські субсидії за словом та фармери
даних подорожні йшли за раз
нові ринки збуту іншим арка
раніше ми експортували до Росії по
над 52 сотками у продукції
нині ми вчимо цифру на мага і муся
прикриті частини на ми там тільки різновид
сотки
там же обличчя так all 1 травня та україни до
повністю замінила росію макросу
там про фінляндія з великого експорту до
сусідньої країни євросоюзу США не видно
єгиптом до них такого активно виходить
на ринку близького відразу тазі та
оптимістично треба, щоб не й самі
фермери за наказом
з коулі парі взявши банківський кредит
majin апертура мільйону євро та побуду у
основу фірму тут розмістити ще десятку
риф купа зазвучали на фінський фермах u2
чим менше за гуллівером автентичністю
добився в мої будні все буде добре там
у і вкладаю в гаю в нову фірму це
курс по що і русь іскри ніг для
нас новий вид крил хоча покійний травня
сина левка лисом sq молочний фермер вже
у шістнадцятому поколінням вінка ж було
і через годину та за режимами
і розум і сином півночі фермерам у 17
поки що рік і молочну установку
до запуску